[Musique]
de cette question là comment on aide les
plus les plus défavorisés qui utilisent
leur voiture moi dans ma circonscription
les gens ils vont travailler en voiture
et ça leur coûte cher donc il faut avoir
un moment de transition et accompagner
aussi tous les tous les sujets qui sont
importants de motorisation des carbonées
et il faut qu'on travaille en même temps
en parallèle entre aider les plus
faibles et avancer sur la décarbonation
des véhicules c'est que comme ça qu'on y
arrivera parce que si on ne si on fait
sans l'aide les gens qui ont aujourd'hui
pas les moyens d'acheter une voiture
électrique ne pourront pas le faire et
on y arriver quand même d'un retour des
gilets jaunes ou d'une forme de
contestation sous une forme d'une autre
avec toute l'inflation qu'il y a on
ressent une difficulté d'un certain
nombre de citoyens et surtout les plus
les plus modestes et comme justement
vous annoncez que l'homme le plus riche
du monde est français il faut qu'on ait
de la justice sociale dans notre pays et
en tout cas nous au groupe modem on y
travaille justement par les super
dividendes et par essayer d'avoir des
politiques juste avant le la ristourne
elle était pour tout le monde maintenant
elle sera pour les plus défavorisée je
trouve ça très bien au sujet
d'inquiétude un demain RTE donc le
réseau de transport électrique et les
préfectures vont faire un test grandeur
nature sur ces délestages ou coupures de
courant il y a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
est-ce que le gouvernement n'alarme-t-il
pas trop ne crée pas finalement de
l'angoisse non le gouvernement il fait
ce que doit faire un gouvernement
c'est-à-dire prévoir et en France on
manque de la culture du risque et je
trouve très bien que sur cette sur ce
sujet là on met en place la culture du
risque comme le frais d'autres pays
c'est-à-dire de prévoir et de prévenir
et puis le président à côté il fait son
rôle de président il rassure c'est
l'épisode masque covid qui a marqué
c'est je pense que c'est l'épisode mask
covid effectivement mais c'est aussi la
nécessité d'avoir une meilleure
appréhension des risques dans notre pays
il y a plein de risques il y a des
risques sanitaires il y a des risques
qui peuvent être des risques
énergétiques les franco-français parce
que un problème
le risque qu'il est européen c'est toute
l'Europe aujourd'hui à des problèmes
en visionnement en énergie en
électricité
du gaz et on a effectivement aujourd'hui
un problème avec nos centrales mais moi
je vous invite à regarder elles sont
toutes en train de repartir en montée de
puissance et c'est très bien et il faut
continuer sur les retraites
dans la
discussion il a été bien géré ce temps
de la négociation de la discussion que
le temps de la discussion il continue et
c'est normal qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il
y ait une discussion en discussion à
plusieurs niveaux le gouvernement avec
les syndicats c'est important mais aussi
le gouvernement et nous parlementaire
avec les citoyens je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse comprendre les enjeux de
cette réforme et que cette réforme elle
soit partagée par tous parce que si elle
n'est pas partagée on y arrivera pas on
y arrivera pas les syndicats
et donc ça veut dire qu'on a un travail
à continuer et quand il faut qu'on
travaille et qui qu'on rabâche les
enjeux et les enjeux pour l'instant non
je vais pas dire ça c'est que c'est pas
facile à vendre une retraite une réforme
des retraites ça jamais été facile à
vendre c'est c'est dans notre pays
souvent l'élément qui crispe le plus dès
qu'on dès qu'on réformes donc il faut
expliquer et au-delà d'expliquer il faut
aussi montrer en quoi cette réforme on
la veut juste en tout cas nous au groupe
modem on veut que ça soit une réforme de
justice sociale et une justice qui
prenne en compte la pénibilité qui
prennent en compte les carrières longues
qui prennent en compte les personnes qui
ont eu des difficultés à avoir un
parcours de vie complet et dans cette
réforme on tient à ce que il y ait ces
éléments et puis après l'âge l'âge de
départ 65 ans moi j'avoue que 65 ans je
trouve que c'est vraiment le dernier des
curseurs je trouve que on pourrait
peut-être envisager 64 et peut-être même
plutôt envisagé non pas un âge 64 65
mais une durée de cotisation et
peut-être que ça serait mieux compris
par les Français en tout cas c'est ça
qui va falloir qu'on ait comme débat
vous allez vous au modem vous faites
partie de la majorité
comment vous allez encore amener votre
on va faire ce qu'on fait au modem
c'est très bien que ça discute s'il y
avait qu'une ligne
je pense que ça voudrait dire que qui
est qu'une qui avec qui a qu'une
solution et on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y
a plusieurs solutions donc on est une
majorité qui débat et on veut surtout
débattre avec les Français et donc nous
on fera ce que dit notre président
Mattei en fera notre drôle de
parlementaire et un parlementaire ça
travaille et ça fait des propositions un
texte à part entière ou dans le projet
de loi rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale et dans ce cas là il y a 49-3
oui mais moi j'avoue que j'ai plutôt une
préférence pour un texte global un texte
qui parle des aspects ce qu'on appelle
paramétrique des aspects d'âge et puis
un texte aussi qui donne des nouvelles
des nouveaux horizons aux Français qui
ont eu des carrières difficiles aux
carrières longues et globaliser le tout
me semble meilleur à loi autre actualité
demain à la Convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie se réunit pour la première
fois il faut changer la loi Leonetti
class alors avant de changer la loi
léonique léonitic qu'il faut en faire un
bilan et c'est ce qui est en cours
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée mais aussi
avec la convention citoyenne qui a été
lancée je trouve que c'est de très bonne
idée de travailler avec une convention
citoyenne la fin de vie c'est
extrêmement intime c'est personnel on a
tous un rapport à la mort différent à la
mort à sa mort à son appréhension de la
mort mais aussi avec des parcours de vie
parfois certains ont accompagné la mort
d'autres non et quand on est
parlementaires c'est des sujets
extrêmement difficiles parce qu'on doit
se mettre à la place des Français et
faire une convention citoyenne je trouve
que c'est une très bonne idée parce que
cette convention citoyenne va pouvoir
au-delà de des débats politiques avoir
une vision de ce que veut la société
parce que ça doit être beaucoup ça doit
être un débat apaisé à la fin de vie il
faut être dans la dans le respect des
convictions de chacun parce qu'il y a
des gens qui ont des convictions qu'il
faut pas y toucher il y a des gens qui
ont des convictions qu'il faut avancer
et ça je suis sûr qu'on peut par le
débat par la compréhension mutuelle et
par le comment dire l'affirmation que
chacun parcourt très personnel par
rapport à ça et que chacun donc doit
avoir la possibilité de choisir et comme
ça on y arrivera je pense parler de la
méthode donc la convention citoyenne et
le précédent de la convention climat ça
a laissé des traces quel poids aura
finalement cette convention citoyenne
elle aura un poids important comme a eu
la convention citoyenne sur le climat la
convention citoyenne sur le climat elle
a posé des éléments sur la table après
il y a eu des décisions qui ont été
prises des décisions qui ont été
arbitrées mais ces questions elles
étaient même pas parfois posées sur la
table et c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans une convention citoyenne c'est que
ça met au débat ça met à l'agenda public
un certain nombre de sujets et ça permet
aux hommes et aux femmes politiques
d'avoir une vision parfois plus globale
de la de la perception dans la société
aura le dernier mot le Parlement mais à
la fin c'est normal que ça soit le
politique et le Parlement qui a qui est
la décision parce que tout simplement
nous sommes la représentation nationale
et nous avons une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos décisions et donc c'est
comme ça que ça doit bien fonctionner
l'articulation entre participation et
représentation merci merci
à nous on se retrouve dans